now the last time you were here Nicole
we enjoyed from your early modelling
work on the late lamented
dolly madly right no beautiful beautiful
I've finally judged work well shot I
think we're done no we're we're not
we're not showing too much okay we have
very others with our lovely pictures of
Keith as I as an emerging a right star
on the Australian music scene here in
Tamworth that is a door no it's really
criminal about that is actually that was
last Tuesday what still is your Jesus I
take a ginger I know the population of
town what's growing Oh
I wasn't recognize you in that picture
but then there's another picture honest
I only know this is you because it's a
Jew this is Keith Urban I mean that's
unbelievable yeah yeah dad never loved
it is irritable is that boy least likely
to marry Nicole Kidman XE detection I
know that we've had the cold water glory
[Laughter]
oh okay well Allan so this is node in
your book this is a if they're haffley a
story or this makes it is around the
same time as keith was wearing very
tight jean you were on a school trip to
Germany without cheese
look we were all doing it and he was
Democrat of a tidy thought I think it's
a girl center to a girl who has at
school was on that school trip
sanatorium via Twitter and I was ah and
I thought why did I have no chosen I
must have taken them off for a bit I
don't know like it's a good look it is a
very calm about it kind of yeah I'm
rocking a short jumper trip I'm going to
translate this theory most men have
excellent legs
people say that yeah it's not it's like
it's I think what I think's interesting
is a lot of men have body parts not body
parts but bits are the bodies that women
desire like slim hair long eyelashes and
I think women think that all men have
better things that they want them then
it's not true I've seen a lot of naked
men
I know thank you
we're known here if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that that hit
subscribe or don't free world but I know
what I do in that situation